ces deux là ont tous gagné ensemble avec
kobo à ses côtés mikaël kingsbury de
deux montagnes qui est devenu l'athlète
le plus prolifique des bosses 48
victoires en coupe du monde dont 13
consécutive un record
mais voilà qu'à l'aube de la nouvelle
saison leurs chemins se séparent t comme
le fun est ensemble du parcours parce
qu'on avait comme cet oral autour de
nous deux on sent bien vous battre ils
ont passé huit ans à parcourir le monde
et a cumulé les titres mais une
restructuration c'est le l'équipe
canadienne a incité à cobo a quitté le
programme national car ça tombait le
c'était comme vous le saviez
c'est c'est un autre chemin tous et mais
c'était la fin du cycle se soit fait que
cet après midi là je peux dire que on
aurait dit que mon fils vivait une peine
d'amour la julie thibodeau se souvient
des premières fois où elle a laissé
partir son fils en europe pour les
compétitions
c'est à rob kober qu'il a confié ce
qu'elle a de plus précieux et que tu
avais pas larges allées d'un bar les
autres l'athlète wii fait après une
coupe du monde et que si j avais
beaucoup d'inquiétude puis je les écoute
mahb mon fils là n'est pas fini alors si
tu vois des choses qui fait que tu
n'accepterait pas de la part de tes
trois enfants mais moi ta carte blanche
on n'est pas loupé et que je t'en prie
c'est comme voisine cobras est devenu
non seulement un entraîneur mais aussi
un complice est un modèle pour kingsbury
je me suis posé plein de questions
j'essaie de me projeter un futur et
c'est de m'avoir thé dans le port scion
des ports avec nouveau coach accessoires
je travaille c'est finalement le
québécois michel hamelin qui
accompagnera le champion un défi tout
aussi excitant qu'angoissant moi je
coche si tu as la chance de coacher mon
niveau
non mais c'est vrai que c'est stressant
autant pour l'athlète que pour le coach
a mené à de l'expérience avec les coeurs
brisés
il avait repris la carrière d'alexandre
bilodeau après son premier titre
olympique en 2010 puis il avait fait de
même avec les soeurs dufour-lapointe
après les jeux de 2014 année mes forces
en tant qu'entraîneur c'est il y appelle
sur l'intelligence émotionnelle avec
j'essaye de mettre dans la peau de ces
gens là j'essaie de voir qu'est ce
qu'ils ont besoin
pas juste une nouveau technique si ce
que je trouve cool de travailler mais
que c'est justement il a été comme moi
et ont gagné la bataille des olympiques
en 2014
mais j'ai gagné toutes les batailles des
globes de cristal qu'entretient des
séries ce côté compétitif michel hamelin
l'avez remarqué dès l'âge de 7-8 ans
chez le jeune mickaël qui participait à
des camps d'entraînement qu'il dirigeait
manège ok on fait une compétition
puis tout d'un coup j'ai vu sa petite
phase les psys et voler comme ça pour
plier devenu en mission il ya sur des
casemates deux fois plus haute au monde
aujourd'hui
kingsbury et le king est incontestable
des bosses avec ses deux médailles
olympiques dont une d'or à pyongyang et
ses 14 globe de cristal consécutif du
jamais vu et la nouvelle équipe prenait
ses adversaires de former un duo encore
plus redoutable ici jacinthe hayon radio
canada montréal
[Applaudissements]